[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show have my
friend Rolf Potts here Roth Potts who is
Roth Ralph is the author of The
International bestseller vagabonding
subtitle an uncommon Guide to the art of
long-term World Travel that was one of
the two books I traveled with in the
Years preceding the writing of the four
hour work week his newest book is the
Vagabonds way 366 meditations on
Wanderlust Discovery and the Art of
travel he is reported from more than 60
countries for National Geographic
traveler the New Yorker outside the New
York Times magazine and Travel Channel
many of his essays have been selected as
notable mentions in the best American
essays the best American non-required
reading and the best American Travel
writing he is based in North Central
Kansas I love how specific that is where
he keeps a small farmhouse on 30 Acres
with his wife kansas-born actress
Kristen Bush my 2014 God how old are we
getting we're off we're going to talk
about that my 2014 interview with Ralph
can be found at tim.blog slash Ralph we
cover a lot of ground in that interview
including a lot of background with
vagamonding we're probably not going to
revisit all of that and we get into all
sorts of nooks and crannies so that is a
self-sustaining independent episode
we're going to try to cover some new
ground in this one you can find Ralph on
Twitter and Instagram at ralphpots
that's
r-o-l-f-p-o-t-t-s and you can also find
everything Ralph rothpots.com Ralph it
is nice to see you again my friend good
to see you again too it's it's funny
2014. gosh it's been a while yeah it has
been a while it's almost coming up on a
decade I mean I'm starting to round up
now getting old enough that I'm like ass
three years until a decade two or three
years that's fine it's more or less a
decade
2014 so a lot has happened since 2014.
yes sir and I thought we would start
with a question that came to my mind as
I Was preparing for this conversation as
I always do and rereading part of the
transcript of our last podcast episode
together
and it's a simple question in a sense
which is
when you think of travel companions or
anyone you could travel with alive or
dead
are there any particular
names or figures who come to mind and
perhaps you just have a suspicion of
what it would be like to travel with
them that's totally fine because really
what I'm hoping to unpack here is why
are you choosing the people you're
choosing whether you know them well or
not at all
you know I'm an old Die Hard Solo
Traveler so like I'm not to be a
curmudgeon necessarily but I'm a big fan
of solo travel just because sort of as
an introvert it forces me to to look
outward and to meet people and not to
travel in a little bubble of self but
you're talking about 2014 our last
podcast interview which was podcast sort
of felt new back then I Was A Bachelor
now I'm married I got I met my wife
during the pandemic I went traveling
with her to Europe for the first time
first time internationally this summer
and so that's my cheat answer basically
that I'm just excited to have this
person I love to travel with and it's
sort of a late life marriage for me and
and that's exciting but that's very
concrete and less speculative
um but it is sort of turning back some
of that solo curmudgeon but yeah if
there was a famous person it almost ties
into like who I was reading during the
pandemic uh because in the pandemic we
couldn't travel I was sitting on my deck
and then I met this woman who became my
wife and so we would start each day by
reading to each other sometimes poetry
actually we read Mary Oliver I know
you're a Mary Oliver fan but we also
read tick not Han I think you probably
are familiar with tick not Han so I'm
thinking like there's the tick not Han
and Thomas Mertens who would be
interested in travel with but those
These Are Spiritual guys and I know that
travel is naturally spiritual but those
guys would be almost too intense I I
think that I would always feel like I
could never measure up to these saintly
monk guys so another guy we read to each
other during the pandemic was Ross Gade
you know the poet's Ross gay I don't he
read about called The Book of delights
and it in these other readings are sort
of part of the model from my new book
the Vagabonds way because it's basically
each page is a day there's a quote and
there's a meditation or a reflection on
the quote and
rosuke's book is a hundred Reflections
and he just seems like a guy I'd like to
hang out with
and he has a great chapter about
loitering and how loitering to him it's
a crime like especially poor or people
who aren't white are sometimes picked up
for loitering but learning is just like
not necessarily doing anything it's it's
being inactive and rosuke says well
actually to me that sounds like a good
time and as I was writing the new book
it occurred to me that actually like
really super luxury vacations like the
image we have of luxury vacations are
people
who have who are wealthy who are paying
a lot of money to do nothing to sit by a
reflecting pool with with a robe on and
do nothing as if you couldn't sit at
home and do nothing right and so travel
becomes this pretext for doing nothing
and so I just like Ross Gay's way of
looking at the world and of course my
wife and I would redo each other every
morning and he's he's not quite as
competitively spiritual as as tick not
Han or Thomas Merton who might make me
feel less than spiritual so he seems
like he'd be a good companion as we find
ways to loiter around the world together
so I have not stayed in a hostel on at
least a handful of years I mean I and I
I used to stay in hostels even if I
could afford a much more expensive hotel
I found that incredibly boring sitting
in a hotel room by myself I can do that
anywhere let me stay in a hostel and do
the bike tours and get to know people
and so on
I imagine I I have not explored this
recently that
that hostels probably mimic many other
environments where you walk in and each
person is glued to a screen and there's
much less engagement I have to imagine
that's true
probably when the booze comes out maybe
things get a little more social that
tends to inevitably be part of the
Hostile experience are there ways that
you might approach it what advice or
thoughts would you share with folks well
I remember the historical technological
moment when that started to shift for me
it was around 2007 actually around the
time before I work week came out
actually
um well I would sit in hostile lounges
and people this is when Wi-Fi was more
ubiquitous and people really locked into
their laptops later became smartphones
and that that sort of communal
environment that happens in the Hostile
Lounge just wasn't happening like it was
before and the great thing about a
hostile Lounge is that like for all of
the planning you do in advance of your
trip and maybe while you're saving up
money it'll take you two years you're
planning all this stuff like one
afternoon in a good hostel lounge with a
bunch of people who were leaving the
country that you're entering or have
been to a lot of the places you've been
to that is like on the Ground
Intelligence that is priceless and so
much better than what you could find
through mediated information actually
George Orwell talked about this in an
essay called the road to Wigan Pier he
said that when you take a train from
Scotland to London you sort of erase the
the experience of that Journey that
would have happened had you walked it
but I can criticize that but I'm not
going to not take the train right I'm
not going to walk to London every time I
want to go there just because there's
more life to be experienced along the
way that serves a purpose right our
mobile devices also serve a purpose it
used to be this idea about 20 years ago
that technology is something that would
allow you to experience the world
without leaving your home right well
unfortunately now we're in a situation
where you can travel and not leave your
home when you experience the world right
you're still looking through the same
screen the same Black Mirror which you
get all of your distractions you're
chatting with the same knucklehead
friends you do usually you know you're
really confining you confining your
experience to the size of this screen so
while I don't want to knock it outright
and I very much do use my my smartphone
I use technology you really have to
navigate that because one of the gifts
of travel is attention it is the actual
experience of things happening it's also
of making mistakes and being an outsider
and being vulnerable and leaving
yourself open to places and so easier
said than done but
actually sometimes it can't hurt to in
that hostile Lounge situation or
wherever to be the to be the person who
interrupts somebody looking at their
phone asking a dumb question
and then sort of breaking that ice
because I think sometimes it is almost
group conformism we're all we've all
defaulted back to our phone we may as
well be in our own bedroom back home but
instead we're in a hostile Lounge making
dumb jokes you know via iMessage with
our friends I think one person
if they're like did you just say that
you came from Chiang Mai I'm going to
Chiang Mai tell me about Chiang Mai that
can start to break the ice it's it's
really just sort of forcing
you and the people around you past that
impulse which is to look back at your
phone and to have this organic wonderful
experiences which which is the gift of
travel even metaphorically
one purpose of travel is to force
yourself into that kind of attention and
that human experience that you sometimes
don't give yourself because we're we're
constantly in distractions at home and
you know they call it the attention
economy and
our our apps are smarter than we are our
apps know how short our attention span
is so in a way we just have to slap down
our apps and their their algorithmically
programmed way of holding our attention
and give our attention to each other as
humans give our attention to the places
where we are the smells the other five
senses right not just the sounds you
hear on your phone or the sites you see
through your apps but what you smell yep
let's smell guide you through a new
place
your mentioned of the attention economy
made me think how much am I selling my
attention for at different points right
and I mean that's more of a metaphor in
the sense that thinking of how much I'm
valuing my attention at different points
right and how am I allocating it as if
it were a budget
and a fixed budget and that's something
I'm gonna actually reflect on because I
have some travel coming up
hmm
is something like Couchsurfing a partial
remedy because the social expectation
perhaps is greater in
a setting like that in the social
arrangement of something like house
serving which I haven't used in a long
time so I don't know if it is alive and
well or if it is now turned into
something else or is defunct I have no
idea
uh more so than say a hostile and
current day
2022.
or how would you think about that in
other words it's even worth going to a
hostel if you're going to have to
assault people to grab the attention to
ask them about Chiang Mai well it's
worth going to a hostel I'm I remain a
fan of hostels for people of any ages
you know there's this they used to be
called youth hostels
and there's a historical reason why
they're called youth hostels but they're
really I've taken my parents to hostels
in their 60s and they loved it yeah so I
don't want to to poo poo that and
actually you mentioned activities
there's tours and dinners and other
times in hostels that will that give you
non-screen time with other with other
humans Couchsurfing is a good
opportunity when you can have it the
Couchsurfing didn't take off like we may
have thought it was Couchsurfing the the
social media site like it was 10 years
ago it's still an option there's also
things like home stays and planned
activities were actually sort of in
local economies instead of staying at a
hostel or a hotel you can just pay a
family to uh to stay at their house and
you it's almost like study abroad but
you're just passing through and
basically the mother is cooking for you
and you're hanging out with the kids and
it's more interactive how would you find
that if you wanted to find that in
destination X let's say
Chiang Mai probably not the example I
would use but let's just say who knows
go to Kansas I'm going to to London I'm
going to
Burma I mean who who knows
what
would be your approach to finding such a
Homestay would you just Google Homestay
fill in the blank place that is exactly
what I was thinking you know I keep
there are lists of homestays I still
maintain my vagabonding.net website and
I have resources that are things about
all kinds of lodging including homestays
and homestays sometimes are more common
in like often they're really common in
Latin America for some reason uh less so
in North America and but yeah that's
that's where you start Google the place
where you are at home stay because it's
a thing and then ask around after them
even ask at the hostel because this can
be really interesting and then you sort
of get into the life of a family who's
in the community you're also directly
paying into the community instead of
having money siphoned off through
middlemen you're just your money is
going to the family they're they're
practicing their English they're cooking
for you they're
benefiting financially directly from
your role there as a guest so just ask
around the curiosity is another great
tool in your toolbox as a traveler just
in any situation just asking questions
from my own podcast I recently
interviewed a woman who decided to go
hitchhiking across Europe looking for
pastry recipes so when she got taken to
a town she would just ask where's the
closest bakery and they're like yeah
there's one up the street and then she
would go and say this is delicious how
do you cook it and people were used to
that and she was just basically that was
her that was her window into the place
and just people opened their hearts and
homes to her because they took interest
in what they no longer thought that much
about and wanted to learn something that
they had so I think that Curiosity for a
Homestay or pastry or just like whatever
I I think you said before that when you
travel you look for something like
martial arts because it gives you a
community it gives you people to be
curious with I think once you once your
screen is down and you have that human
being in the room your curiosity is
going to lead you in all these
directions that you had no idea existed
before you started asking after those
things yeah totally and your story about
the pastries made me think of a story
that Cal fussman told me so Cal Foss
been
writer interviewer extraordinaire he
wrote the I think it's what I learned
what I've learned
column for Esquire magazine for a very
long time so he interviewed Gorbachev
and Muhammad Ali and everybody you can
imagine
and what he did when he was he when he
was very young and traveling
internationally with no money
when he didn't know where he was going
to stay that night or the next night
he'd get on a bus going from point A to
point B and he would try to find a
grandma to sit next to and he would ask
as as his example like how do you make
the best goulash and like by the end of
the trip he'd have a place to stay he'd
have amazing goulash the people around
him on the bus would be curious about
what the grandma was saying and they
debated or they'd agree and it turned
into a whole mini community on this bus
on route to wherever he was going
without any plan whatsoever So Cal is a
great example because he's an
interviewer right so he has sort of
perfected the art of sort of
ingratiating himself and getting on
their good side and so curiosity is his
job description yet we all have
curiosity in our toolkit as Travelers of
just I'm just thinking in Kansas like
basically anybody who comes in a
non-tourist statement like Kansas where
I'm talking to you from now and speaking
of foreign accent they're immediately
going to have the interest of whoever is
talking to them because this is a pretty
isolated part of the country in that
same way curiosity about the most basic
things I guess and this Cal will tell
you this as an interviewer people maybe
Mikhail Gorbachev is a different example
but most people aren't used to people
taking an interest in them right yeah
and so if you're asking for a pastry
recipe for a goulash recipe if you're
saying is there a place around here
where there's a pickup game of soccer or
basketball or something then suddenly
people in their family don't ask that
all of a sudden you're taking an
interest in in these smaller parts of
their lives and suddenly the door swings
wide open to an experience of travel
yeah that is not something that's a
consumer experience but it's just one of
the gifts of being in a new place
so to double down on the pastry story
yeah it strikes me that
and we've spoken about this
on multiple occasions both recorded and
unrecorded about the The Perils of being
over scheduled or over determined in
your plans for travel let's just say not
leaving much
space for improvisation or
adaptability in your plans and
as I was prepping for this
I was contemplating the different
reasons that people may be inclined to
do that
or they end up being reactive or they
end up on their phones all the time even
though they've been waiting six months
to go to Paris right and then they're
nonetheless they're on their phones all
the time why is that
and it strikes me that one plausible
answer is that they don't have a
focusing
theme or through line in the same way
that that woman you mentioned had with
pastries it's a focusing function
and perhaps you could speak to
inventing or different missions one
could have
Kevin Kelly photography might be an
example but could you perhaps just give
a handful of such examples because I do
think that
it's not just for the benefit of the
mission that you have a mission there's
a lot of collateral benefit that
radiates out from that
absolutely yeah I mentioned Kevin Kelly
in my new book as a guy who he set out
like he wanted to be a photographer for
National Geographic and so he called the
office and they're like yeah kid you're
17 years old no thanks so we decided to
go to Asia and take photos anyway and so
he traveled with like 500 rolls of film
and one spare shirt it's a great story
and he just started taking photos and he
traveled there for like nine years and
so while other Backpackers were sort of
partying and not really sure what they
were going to do he had a mission he was
out taking photos and to this day he has
a new he has a new book out of his Asia
photos
it's it's amazing Vanishing Asia
Vanishing 30-year plus project yeah yeah
I contributed to that Kickstarter or
whatever just because I I believe in in
his vision as a photographer because he
threw himself into it like what
university was going to give him that
experience of nine years of shooting
film every day in Asia another thing is
I was in Sumatra like the last year
before the pandemic early in 2019 I was
in Sumatra and I was staying at this eco
lodge on this on this little isolated
part of the island I love Sumatra so
much and I was hanging out with birders
and Surfers and these are some of the
happiest Travelers I've ever met because
the birders would just would pay so much
attention I'd be eating my dinner in the
lodge and they start arguing over like
something that they see hundreds of
yards away in the tree that I can't even
see like they have something through
which the lens of their travels forces
them to pay attention to what other
people Overlook which is Birds which are
everywhere right and so as the more I
spent time in too much and the more I
realized if I just sit still and stop
being bored I bet there's things in
these trees and so I saw my cakes and
and birds and amazing things just by
allowing myself to be still the Surfers
are great because they're just looking
for waves and in a certain sense the
surface I met they're they're great guys
but they're sort of crappy Travelers
because they're not interested in
anything that's Inland right like I went
to Lake Topo which is one of the great
Sumatran places it's this volcanic Lake
where you can get like an eight dollar
guest house and jump off the rail of
your balcony and swim in this Vault can
it Caldera and I'm like yeah no I
haven't heard of it like because it's
not on the ocean right but they were
learning Bahasa Indonesian so well they
knew their Maps they were such capable
Travelers because they used their their
Obsession as as a map for learning all
the other skills that fell into place as
Travelers and so whereas some other very
young capable smart Travelers I knew
would always default into boredom mode
by looking at their phone it's that same
Instinct you have back home you look at
your phone you fall asleep you wake up
you look at your phone that frames your
days these guys are just thinking about
waves and it taught them language skills
it taught them food skills it was such a
it made me wish I was a better Surfer
because it made me realize that having
that kind of obsession be it pastries
are surfing is really a great pretext to
have Adventures that you could never
imagine before you left home
you mentioned something a few minutes
ago that I had not been aware of so you
said I took my parents who were in their
60s now
you're not an ancient guy by any stretch
but you're also no spring chicken right
so how old were your pet how old were
your parents when they had you
oh no no well this was this happened a
long time ago that was 20 years ago yeah
okay my parents are pushing 80s now so
sorry sorry for the timeline discrepancy
but they you know they had gray hair
they were retired it's funny how at the
time I thought they were really old like
now I'm in my early 50s and 60s was like
right around the corner and it doesn't
feel like it's gonna be that old but the
time I was used to being sort of this
solo Dirtbag he was just up for anything
and just living out of a rucksack and
doing what I wanted and then suddenly my
parents were with me and I was thinking
okay whatever but we were in China right
and Chinese culture really respects age
and my parents are School teachers and
they're just curious about everything
but it actually happened in Europe too
people thought my parents were cute you
know even even as they were sort of
incompetent wandering around Paris and
Prague it was such a great pretext and a
good reminder that expertise is less
important than open-heartedness and
curiosity because in a way the roles
reversed I was the parent I was the
expert I was the one who was trying to
keep them out of trouble making sure
they were fed and they were just
throwing themselves into every day and
the thing about the hostels is
this is a great thing about travel
culture too is that it was rare that
people would would be not interested in
them just because they were 40 years
older than them right that they just
thought fair enough you're standing in
the hostel I'm going to treat you like
anybody else yeah so it was so cool to
see the young people bend towards what
my parents were up to and my parents do
the same and it was it was a really
great experience and it made me realize
that
yeah I hope I travel until the day I
drop dead because it really keeps you
new and fresh and vulnerable to new
experiences in a way that that uh it's
hard to pull off at home and it was fun
to see yeah totally so comment and then
then a follow-up so the comment is
and I've done this I just hadn't
recalled it when we were chatting about
hostels earlier I have gone to hostels
to just talk to the people who work
there and not to stay at the hostel
because you have it's maybe going to
sound like a strange comparison but for
people who've seen Game of Thrones you
have like the spider
who's this this Hub of all information
and knows exactly what's going on in the
in the the you know the town and the
city gossip and what's happening in the
realm and on uh on a benevolent side
we're not looking at a character exactly
as as the spiders depicted in Game of
Thrones the a lot of the folks who work
in hostels just have all of their
fingers on the pulse of what is
happening and so you can also just
wander in and have a cup of coffee and
chat them up for a bit and ask for a few
recommendations and not necessarily stay
in the hospital but the hospital does
have the effect to your comment about
your parents is breaking down a lot of
the
social barriers that our cultures have
constructed or that we have constructed
right the separation of generations that
you tend to see in North America much
more than South America and so on the
question that I want to ask was
as the solo dirt bag traveler get up and
go anytime
marriage now what happened I mean I'm
not saying that in a bad way but how did
you personally arrive at a point where
you're like okay I think this is the
next step
it's a good question and I wish there
could be some sort of replicable lesson
here you know that if you just do this
during a pandemic you'll meet your soul
mate but I just through dumb luck and a
dating app I I met my person you know I
met my soulmate during the pandemic it's
funny she's from Kansas I'm from Kansas
I've sort of been
searching for my Kansas girl on the
other side of the world and she was on
the other side of the world she was
living in Europe when pandemic happened
she came back to be close to her family
I was living close to my family we were
both sort of bored on a dating app one
day and it's like wait a second really
you're out there and it just went from
zero to let's get married in in no time
flat uh and so so in a way I just I met
the right person and it was great but I
think
I I think just being open to that and
and realizing that was a thing I I think
as a dirtbag traveler and I've always
been a proud Dirtbag traveler there's
some some compromises you make in life
where you think
I'm sort of sacrificing traditional love
for an interesting life and for freedom
and for flexibility and for the ability
to be anywhere at any time and then you
meet this person then you meet your
person it's like all those song lyrics
that you sort of rolled your eyes at
when in your 20s
suddenly makes sense it's like yeah yeah
sure give me a give me an old 60s Motown
song about love and that's that's what
I'm experiencing with this person and so
it's great it's the ability to
experience something and it's not like I
fell in love for the first time but
experienced that full-throated
full-hearted all-in love when I was when
I was pushing 50 was fun to see and
there's almost a travel parallel in that
in that sense in that you're always
seeking newness and I think I sort of
had a scab over my heart in a certain
sense because travel was so rewarding
and the freedom to travel was so
rewarding that I didn't realize I could
have it both and then suddenly I met
this person it's like oh and I think
when I proposed marriage I used
waltman's line you know I give you my
hand I give you my love more precious
than money will you come travel with me
shall we stick together as long as we
live if I didn't quote that directly I
paraphrase it because it's like yes this
is my person come travel with me and
come stay here with me too we have a
good life here in Kansas as well but
it's interesting and this probably
doesn't happen to most people I think a
lot of people really get into the love
mindset in that in that age that
features romantic comedies you're in
your 20s or whatever
but for some reason I thought the uh the
price of an interesting life was not
having traditional love relationship and
I was I was blown away to have a to fall
in love during the pandemic with my
person so so let's dig a bit further on
that you're an excellent writer a man of
words a man of letters
how would you describe this
experience what was different how were
you different in responding to it as you
said not your first time falling in love
and love can also be an umbrella term
that covers a lot of different species
of what we might call love so what what
was different about you about her about
the two of you
you've had you've been exposed to a lot
of things in a lot of places
so what was it I enjoyed being a
bachelor back when I was one
man and I've told my wife sometimes we
should have met 10 years earlier like
this 10 years would have been way more
interesting if you would have been in it
right and she's here yeah I'm not sure
if we're getting ready I'm not sure if I
would have been ready for you and you
for me and so I think sometimes maybe
I'm a person who just needed to grow a
little bit you know to be more
open-hearted to be ready to meet this
person and I'm suddenly this believer in
fate
but I I sort of needed to work through
some things I needed to travel some and
just sort of get a sense to where I
realized I needed that you know that I
wouldn't have lived a complete life I I
needed my other half you know I needed
that full-throated open-hearted love and
it sort of caught me by surprise but now
that I have it it just doesn't make
sense it's like what I was what was I
doing all those years before I met my
wife so
does that answer your question are you I
think it does I think it does I suppose
I'm hearing the
you being more prepared on some level
even though it perhaps it wasn't a
conscious preparation for this but
having changed over time become more
open-hearted
you also
I would imagine probably thought through
what proposing and getting married would
mean
I suppose if you have any other pieces
of advice or suggestions for folks out
there maybe one who you're talking to
who is no I'd say getting to if not
having already passed the midpoint in
life
who has not yet arrived there all right
what would you say
I think that that needs to be worked
through I think too many people in all
societies marry too soon because it's
sort of expected I think it will
complete them somehow
I think working through ambivalence or
through uncertainty is an important
thing you know I had
I had a concussion I wrecked a
motorcycle in Asia in 2019 and it led me
into some post-concussive depression and
I think sometimes that experience I
think actually I'm not sure how
hardwired for depression I am I'm sort
of this reflexive Optimist but it also
felt seasonal depression sometimes and
so it was probably always there but just
sort of working through sort of having
my my head knocked in a little bit and
being
you know sort of working through dealing
with aloneness and sadness and realizing
that being completely an island away
from other people is not necessarily a
desirable thing and I don't think that
depression necessarily is going to
compel someone to just marry the next
person who walks in the door I think I
was very lucky to meet someone who's
very well suited to be with me and I
with her
but I think
working through those just realizing
it's something you need like I think I
think I realized I needed that kind of
love before I met my wife and when I met
my wife it's like oh well there you are
right and so I worry my nightmare is
that I may have met her 10 years earlier
and not recognized the the way that she
completed my way of being in the world
and so I would say don't don't be afraid
of those negatives and the sadness and
and sort of trying but but be honest
with yourself I think sometimes maybe
men have a problem with this more than
women is that that self-sufficiency
trying to be completely self-contained
and having freedom and not really having
obligations to other people in life
doesn't always yield happiness in a way
that that sort of yoking yourself to
somebody else's life can and so I can
speak with expertise about travel less
so with love I still feel like I was
really blindsided by it and again very
lucky to to have experienced it in the
full throated way that I did
but I think just sort of working through
it and realizing that complete
Independence and and sort of being
pinched off from other people in the
world is not necessarily the best way to
live
so I must I must ask you if it's come up
a few times what do you mean by
full-throated full-hearted I've heard
full throated yeah sorry maybe that's a
poetic term full-throated is like
speaking it aloud right like I'm I'm a
Midwestern guy and so yeah we stand far
apart We Don't Hug as much we don't say
as much right full throat it is when
it's like you know you verbally State
your love you know it's not just
you know I love you hon you know I love
you no it's when it's when you think
about it so often that you have to say
it yeah got it okay I'm glad I asked did
you always suspect that you would end up
back in Kansas or did you think that was
the furthest thing from
any possible Geographic
I don't say resting place because you're
not resting obviously you're dead but
did you foresee ending up back in in
Kansas was that something that you had
as your homing beacon in some respect or
was that not the case
I don't think so I think I always had a
fondness for Kansas and I always when my
dad was a was a high school science
teacher in Kansas and so I went a lot of
field trips with him and and I was I was
allowed to see Kansas as a naturalist
might you know to see the grass and
realize that
the grass may be one foot above the
ground but those roots go 20 feet down
and it's part of an ecosystem and
there's actually dinosaur bones because
Kansas used to be a sea so being raised
by a science teacher sort of helped me
appreciate the subtleties of a landscape
like Kansas but Kansas is not a very
sexy or exciting place right yet I
always held this tenderness for it but I
I sort of figured when I was younger
that I would end up
you know in in in a Portland or a Paris
or or a New York or someplace like that
and actually this actually ties into my
family as well because one thing I
learned from travel is that almost
anywhere in the world and we can forget
this sometimes in the United States
family is a core value you know you go
to Southeast Asia and one of the first
questions are are you're married it's
like no oh you're 27 you're not married
oh I'm so sorry you know like do you
have kids the family is just this core
value everywhere in the world and we've
sort of allowed ourselves to read that
anyway I I would see people in Vietnam
in in Egypt pulling the resources as a
family to get like real estate or to
share in different burdens and joys
together and so gosh it's been almost 18
years some land came up for sale in
Kansas and um
I couldn't afford it by myself so I
talked my parents into getting another
half of the property another house with
me and they've been my neighbors they
just moved into assisted living recently
but they were my neighbors for 17 years
and it was really great because they
keep an eye on my house when I was gone
things are dirt cheap and in Kansas
you've talked about Geo Arbitrage many
times before it's it's the Great Plains
is is the dirt cheap place to live and
and this is something I talked about in
my first book Vagabond and the idea of
you know travel doesn't necessarily need
to make you unemployable well now we
live in an age where you're interviewing
me you know via VIA my laptop that we
can actually do our jobs remotely
through computers in a way that where
you are you don't have to be like two
Subway rides from that office in
Manhattan now to do good work for an
important company or a publisher or a
media organization now you can sit in a
beloved place like Kansas I love it here
and yeah my first date with my wife was
just on the other side of this door here
and um
that is a travel one
joy and I think thanks to technology and
I critique technology a little bit in my
new book but thanks to technology we can
root ourselves to a quiet place where
there's lots of space and things aren't
that expensive yet participate in the
greater world
you know human culture has been
urbanizing since the Industrial
Revolution and maybe
this new technology will allow us to
sort of have a counter movement against
that urbanization nothing against cities
but sometimes it's nice to be in a more
remote peaceful place where you can you
can go for a Four Mile Walk and not see
anybody and see that as a good thing
I feel you as I get older and more
cantankerous maybe just more sensitive
maybe reclaiming the sensitivity that I
had as a child but beat into submission
one way or another I definitely long for
that type of immersion not necessarily
in solitude but in nature
which I think you can certainly do
without pure Solitude let me read a few
lines that are from the new book and
then I would love to hear any stories or
examples that you can give so
let's start with
one here quote the most meaningful task
for the traveler May well be to look
past what feels exotic and learn to
savor subtle differences in the things
we already have
in common could you elaborate on that
maybe give
any examples well this ties into the
first example that I thought was just
this family situation you know I was in
I was in Vietnam I was in Namibia I was
in Italy and seeing how families would
pull resources and
whereas I could have been in those
places and seeing the most obvious
foreign thing you know I could have
looked for the the himba tribes women in
Namibia who played their hair with ocher
right I could have looked for certain
very stereotypically Vietnamese ways
that people dressed or ate and there's
there's nothing wrong with enjoying
difference but what resonated with me
with from those places was how people
related to family at a souvenir vendor I
wrote a book about souvenirs and in
namibian I was talking to him about it
just sort of seemed like a rough job he
was on a beach and on the skeleton coast
of Namibia like the tourist attractions
are shipwrecks and so he's like just
selling rocks that he dug out of the
mountain you know semi-precious stones
to tourists and it's like where's your
pleasure in this and it's like oh this
isn't worked this is love this is love
for my family this is love for my
daughter this is love for my wife this
is love for my son and so where I might
have been tempted to see him as this
exotic guy who sells rocks for a living
to tourists suddenly he he exemplified
his love of family in a way that I
couldn't have expressed like I was sort
of trying to say don't you feel bad that
you're just you're just a souvenir
vendor and he's like no no no this is
love I'm bringing a better life to my
family up in the mountains and so that's
that's one example like family is such a
universal way that we can look past
I think we all around the world have
similar familial relationships or love
relationships and so seeing that like
another thing that just popped into my
head is uh I lived in Korea for two
years like watching soap operas in Korea
and how it's same same but different as
they say and just sort of seeing how
romantic love is romantic love but like
the manner system within Korea is a
little bit different so the plots are
sort of being strained through the
confucianist culture of Korea in a way
that you wouldn't see in soap operas in
the United States and so I think that we
can go and you see it too much on
Instagram people go to another part of
the world and it's like here's the most
stereotypically dressed tribes person in
this place where I am here's a German
person wearing Lederhosen when in fact
at the end of the day the most
interesting thing about all those people
is things how they relate to love how
they relate to family how they relate to
sports and things like that and I think
I think I use you as an example in the
new book as someone you talk about
porting martial arts new countries and
you instantly have a community and you
can look beyond that and I think the
camaraderie I talk about communitas in
the new book among Travelers that
basically the fact that you're all doing
the same thing at the same time gives
you what is called communitas which is
shared experience pilgrims on a
pilgrimage will do that that's why
pilgrimages are special to people
because communicatas means okay this
woman is 68 years old Italian and
Catholic you know I'm 24 and from
Alabama but we're doing this one step at
a time and communitas gives us a
connection that we wouldn't normally
have had and so I love that about travel
I love those common experiences and I
don't know if you are a pilgrim of
martial arts but certainly you've talked
before about how you have an instant
Community when you take a skill to
another place
yeah absolutely and it breaks down those
barriers that can otherwise exist so
easily not just in North American
society or American society but
elsewhere and at the end of the day if
you're in
even in the U.S you can do this of
course right I remember training long
time ago in San Jose California at this
place called AKA American cake boxing
Academy and they have some tremendous
tremendous competitors I mean I don't
hold a candle to one tenth of any of
them but in the process of training
it was it was funny how after even
several months
there were
tons of people in the class who didn't
know my first name right I was just like
that guy who's good at one particular
thing and then I knew this other guy and
he had some nickname you know whistle
puff or whatever that the coach had
given him had no idea what this guy's
real name was but he was I knew he was
really good at you know triangle choke
and a b and c and uh it was beautiful in
that way nobody I nobody knew what I did
professionally I had no idea what they
did professionally all that mattered was
that shared experience of of training
and they all people cared about was how
serious you were that was it it was very
refreshing we're really really
refreshing in that way I miss that I
actually would like to compete again in
something I think I'm too arthritic and
a little too creaky at 45 for the
martial arts competition
but let me ask you a question about
pilgrimage because as it so happens I am
going to be heading to Japan in the next
handful of months to
walk a portion of the kumanokodo which
is the pilgrimage
I can't really say Trail because it's
actually a whole network of different
trails that wind through Japan
but it's thought of as the the sister
pilgrimage to the coming of the Santiago
and in fact when you get your stamp book
one side is the Camino de Santiago on
the other side is this
I'll be walking with seven or eight
people most of them strangers
what advice would you give for getting
the most out of that it's going to be
probably
seven to ten days long walking most of
the day
any thoughts this is not something I've
never done a pilgrimage an actual
pilgrimage or at least pilgrimage Trail
for that period of time I've done one or
two days at a time here and there but
nothing of that duration
are you bringing your phone
well I I'm not saying you shouldn't yeah
but yeah my default would be to have my
phone however I have kept Verizon
instead of a t because Verizon has worse
international coverage so generally with
Verizon I can't use my phone
unless I use an esim of some type like
gigsky which actually works really well
I use that in in Chile and Antarctica or
on on route to Antarctica
but I try not to use my phone so very
often actually the last time I was in
Japan what I did is I just downloaded a
few offline maps which you can do on
Google Maps so you could use the wi-fi
at the hotel to download a couple maps
and then I would go out and I was Flying
Blind aside from the the maps on the
phone and maybe a camera so I'd be open
to not taking it
because there will be people on the trip
who are going to be taking copious
photographs I don't think I will need to
duplicate any of that
so I could take or not take yeah but do
you know the American writer who writes
about Japan a lot Craig Maude you know
Craig mod you're right yeah sometimes
yeah yeah yeah yeah he's got some great
stuff and I haven't heard it but I I
hear through reliable sources that his
Japanese is also spectacular and
that's him that's impressive that's hard
to do as an adult that's very hard to do
as an adult yeah I'm impressed by his
Japan chops and I actually quote him in
the Vagabonds way because he goes on a
pilgrimage and
I think he downloaded some maps in
Wikipedia and maybe
was able to access a few blogs offline
nothing else worked during the hike and
his exercise was hellos he would say
hello to everybody
presumably in Japanese because you know
the Japanese people are like oh here's
an American and that was almost his his
Mantra is just like hello and basically
that sort of gave him energy during his
pilgrimage is that in because he knew he
knew his default was always looking down
on his phone and he's become that way
for all of us because the algorithm is
smarter than all of us and so saying
hello was his was his go-to and I think
that's great advice for your journey as
well whether or not you bring your phone
I say if you're willing to try it don't
bring your phone that could be a good
experiment you know yeah totally I'm not
a fan of smartphones but I usually bring
them and the GPS comes in handy it's
actually good for your hippocampus to be
lost you can it's actually good against
neurodegenerative diseases
to be lost and to figure out your way
they say that Lundy cab drivers before
GPS had the most developed hippocampuses
in the world so yeah that would be it is
it be independent of the Black Mirror of
your device as much as possible and
maybe this is this is a
psychogeographical strategy we may have
talked about this a little bit when you
were in Paris years ago but find ways to
play games with your sense of place and
phenera is one strategy would you just
sort of wander you wander into the
experience of the city you're not
following a map but you're sort of
following what captures your interests
psychogeography is to sort of create a
little trick to make yourself pay
attention and so for Craig it was saying
hello to people on the trail but maybe
you could think of something else maybe
you're going to collect something or
maybe you'll be a bird watcher or a
surfer or whatever but maybe find like a
a little bag of six little tricks that
you're looking for a little ways to
force yourself to pay attention and it's
a shame that in the 21st century we have
to do that we have to force ourselves to
pay non-digital attention to things but
travel is a great pretext and I I'm I'm
actually excited to hear how it turns
out Tim all I'm super excited I can't
wait to get back it's been a number of
years still close with my host family
from age 15 and really want to see them
and that's wild man it's wild you know
my younger brother my younger host
brother now has like three or four kids
runs three companies it's just bizarre
because he's always Frozen in time for
me is this little brat
it's just wild to think about
and I will say for people who may want
to experiment with this that about two
years ago I just surrendered and
accepted as you said that the the
algorithm specifically the
the armies of Engineers and computer
science phds and now certainly you know
machine learning and AI
are so overwhelmingly favored to win any
Battle of tension with an individual
that you you are I was going to say
bringing a knife to a gunfight but
that's not even you're bringing a
Matchstick like a Matchstick to a
gunfight I mean you just have almost no
hope
to put up much resistance so I removed
all social apps from my phone two years
ago and have missed exactly nothing
because you can still access it if you
need to
or want to through laptop although it's
a little more difficult with certain
platforms because they recognize that
they want to hook you on the cocaine
dispenser so they force you to use
mobile so that it can track you and do
all sorts of other things that I don't
like but it has had to my knowledge
nothing but positive impact on me
professionally allowing me to focus and
batch and so on and if you want to post
on Instagram guess what you can do it in
batches right and you can use something
else a surrogate say like a buffer app
or meet Edgar one of these Services you
don't actually need to be scrolling
through your feed ever necessarily so
that has been very helpful but even the
messaging apps now are so distracting I
mean it's like you've got WhatsApp and
iMessage and signal and Telegram and
everybody uses something different and
it just becomes a whack-a-mole so maybe
I will leave my phone at home certainly
with seven or eight people who are
mostly technologists of some sort I'm
not worried about dying in the forest
it's not not a concern not a concern at
all get a stack of postcards and every
time you want to send a text message
send them a two-week postcard instead
yeah that's a good idea yes stack
backpack full of postcards all right let
me ask you to another or it's not really
an ask but it's to mention another quote
from the from the new book
and you can expand in any way you like
would love any
if any stories or examples come to mind
of course because that's just how my
mind works quote in an information
drenched society that tempts us to
choose unhappiness over uncertainty it
is helpful to remember that one of the
key Gifts of travel has always been
uncertainty itself
I could have been paraphrasing you I
feel like we talked about this or that
that's a phrase that I know is probably
not too foreign to you no it's not and
this really falls into the idea of of
preparation versus leaving yourself open
to chance which is really the gift of
travel
and that goes into the ideas of flurring
your way through a city or using
psychogeography to surprise yourself to
sort of force yourself into being
surprised by a place because in a way if
we bring a menu of options to a place
then we're sort of bound by the size and
of the menu and what's on that menu
whereas if we throw the menu away and we
just and this is a metaphor not just
talking about food if we're open to any
kinds of experiences
then you can experience what you didn't
expect to find like once I was wandering
through Cambodia and I had a lot of
great experiences back in my Dirtbag
Backpacker days and I'm a pretty tall
guy I was like the tallest guy by a head
in Cambodia and I got invited to a
volleyball game because these local
villager guys thought I would be the
ringer and ladies and gentlemen I've
never had my ass handed to me in sports
so much by these guys in Cambodia who
were so much smaller than me they
actually kicked me off the team they
brought me on as a ringer and they
kicked me off because I'm I'm reasonably
athletic but these guys just loved lived
and breathed volleyball and actually
Asia is a great volleyball culture if
that's your sport and so I think had I
gone into that experience just with my
anchor watt map I wouldn't have had that
deep humility that came and then the
friendship that happened afterwards you
know the beers the guys I made their day
by being the six foot three guy who was
just completely inferior to them in
volleyball and that's just one of many
experiences where you just
one of my mantras is walk until your day
becomes interesting because then things
happen to you instead of going with
expectations about something that will
happen to you you just sort of walk and
and what happens happens you let go of
that uncertainty to a little bit because
sometimes we're sort of task driven
people back home but why not just let a
day breathe why not just walk until you
get your ass handed to you in volleyball
or somebody wants to invite you to uh to
a festival I mean
this happens more often in places where
you're obviously not from there I think
I was a little bit spoiled by spending
the first eight years of my
international travel career in Asia
where I don't look very Asian and so I
was understatement of the conversation
yes you do not look very Asian this is
true I do not location and so I had the
privilege and it really is a privilege
of obviously not being from this place
and so it's like let's talk to this dude
he's not from here right and so it gives
so many rewards and I feel like that
scab that uncertainty scab I peeled off
a long time ago because it's been so
rewarding in life and I think maybe Asia
cured that of it it's just like here's
here's the Pasty guy let's go bring him
to our parents or let's go include him
in this soccer game or let's go see if
he wants to eat these these boiled fish
eyes or whatever and it just makes it
makes the experience more interesting
and so I think sometimes the uncertainty
isn't really uncertainty in the face of
danger but just uncertainty in the face
of not having a list of things to do and
not having a set itinerary for a given
day I love museums but at the end of the
day it's those weird random getting your
butt kicked in volleyball moments that
are much more memorable and lead to
these connections that no amount of
certainty
could give you and that's what
uncertainty does give you
are there any particular tactics or
recommendations let's say somebody
agrees with us they're like I totally
agree with what you're saying every trip
I've taken has been pretty tightly
scheduled
what do you suggest right so you can
walk until the day becomes interesting
and get lost especially in a place like
Japan I mean it's so safe generally
speaking it's uh fantastic plus the
English at least when I was last there a
few years ago I mean the English level
tends to be quite low so you
automatically get more excitement that
way and do you have any other
suggestions I mean one thing that came
to mind for me for instance I was like
look if if you're in Japan you get and
you're wandering at getting lost and
let's say you don't find a cool park or
this that other thing some big
obvious
point of focus you could also just
decide you know today I'm going to walk
and get lost and I'm going to go into
every convenience store and try to
notice the things that are different
in those convenience stores because they
are quite different even if you go into
say a 7-Eleven in Japan they are not the
same as the 7-Eleven in the United
States and that might sound really
stupid but you you start to notice a lot
of little details and any other
suggestions for injecting some
uncertainty if somebody wanted as funny
as this might sound you know
instructions for injecting uncertainty
yeah well I think to your 7-Eleven in
Japan example people who are in a hurry
to get to those five tourist attractions
don't have time to to linger in the
7-Eleven and see how weird there's those
bean paste sweet things that you buy
there right oh yeah and so really slow
down if you have if you have 10 days in
this country spin them all in one town
or spend them all in one region and
don't force yourself to Rush from one
place to another one of the philosophers
I quoted in the new book is uh
byeungchol Han have you heard of uh I
think he has a book I think it's called
the scent of time oh great title yeah
well he talks about how you can't fast
forward
sense like of the five senses like
there's probably people who are
listening to this right now on double
speed or 1.5 speed you can fast forward
sound you can fast forward through a
movie right you can't fast forward
through the smells of a market right
yeah so he talks about smell is the
ultimate slow sense and basically his
his philosophy is that
it's a Swiss Korean guy
is that it's the experience of duration
that counts in life not the number of
experiences right he's actually a pretty
abstract philosopher his book is a
little bit slow to read but it's such a
great point and applies to travel so
much in that it is that day where you go
from convenience march to convenience
Mark and see how they're different that
counts it's it's that ex it's the
duration of that day that is more
meaningful than than those five tourist
attractions that you might have gone to
before you and I have hung out in Paris
before and actually we had a great walk
in Paris which we can talk about if you
want but oftentimes I have friends
students will come to Paris and it's
like I ordered lunch and it took them
forever to serve my lunch and then I
wanted the bill and it took them forever
I had to find the guy and it's like I
wanted to experience Paris but I was
sitting in this restaurant waiting for
my bill it's like no no no
that three-hour lunch is the experience
of Paris you know the parisians are not
standing in line for the Louvre I'm not
going to knock the Louvre it's fine but
that was the most Parisian thing you
experienced that day was sitting for
three hours and just sort of watching
the world go past you you know if you're
willing to sit still then you know you
are a spectator in daily life of the
world and so yeah yeah I think about uh
young child Han's philosophy quite a bit
that it's it's the experience of
duration if you can find ways to savor
experience to slow it down and to notice
that from that cafe table in Paris it's
just as Parisian as any other part of
the city and you can actually watch it
with more attention to detail and this
doesn't just pass but anywhere if you
slow down and instead of moving through
a place let that place move through you
for a while it's gonna be so much more
affecting
are there any other books or thinkers
writers movies doesn't really matter
anything at all that
has had an impact on your ability to
maybe extend your perception of time
slow the passage of time increase your
savoring of time
anything like that I mean you mentioned
the scent of time I'll I'll throw one
out there and buy some time so I read a
novel it was gifted to me by my brother
who has a very high bar and it took me
several attempts to get through the
first hundred Pages because it's very
dense and you can't put it down after 13
pages and pick it up for seven pages two
days later and then read another 12
pages that will never work you have to
kind of get the balls in the air and
juggle so that your short-term memory is
doing some work but that novel once you
get if you get to the talking fish I'll
only leave it at that you'll realize oh
okay this is about to get very strange
indeed and that book had a profound
impact on my way of perceiving the world
in time for a few weeks it was very very
cool experience are there any other
books writers thinkers experiences that
people might be able to look to
themselves that have changed your
experience of time or your ability to
slow down
I've been weirdly obsessed with time
ever since I met this guy in a monastery
in Massachusetts on my first Vagabond
trip I was like 23. this dude wherever
he is thank you whoever you are he he
just left the Navy he was and he was he
was in the contemplation room of a
monastery and I I didn't want to become
a Trappist monk but it's like the only
place where I could stay for free and I
was a dirtbag and I wanted to stay there
and this guy he was just out of the Navy
he wasn't necessarily going to become a
monk but he was really interested in
monasticism and he had this skull and
crossbones on his arm and that's where I
learned the phrase Memento Mori I had no
idea what momentum or I remember death
is the philosophical idea of remember
death and I've been thinking about it
ever since you know actually one of The
Inspirations for me as a traveler you
know for vagabonding and up to the new
book is just the idea of that life
doesn't necessarily reward you in time
my grandfather was a Kansas farmer he
worked really hard from the age 15 he
dropped out of school took over the farm
when his dad died worked his ass off and
then when he got to retirement age his
wife grandmother got Alzheimer's disease
and he took care of her for the rest of
his life and so it was a really
heartbreaking thing when I was young but
I realized that you sort of that time
isn't just given to you in a rational
way in life you have to grab time as as
you were allowed to grab it and so I
mean there's great writing about time is
it Oliver Berkman I think I think he
recorded other people of 4 000 weeks I
think four thousand weeks yeah no I've I
haven't finished that book but it's and
I I always read like 10 books at once
but the philosophy of time and the idea
of time and now the scent of time is
something that I've always sort of
Obsessed about and actually one of my
favorite filmmakers is Richard linklater
who and time is sort of one of the
things he experiments in as a filmmaker
and you know I love Before Sunrise
because it's about who a guy who meets
his his true love you know on a train in
in Austria well I met my wife the one
time I wasn't traveling but that's still
a very meaningful movie to me because
they talk so much about time in that
trilogy and they talk about journaling
you know which is something I know you
talk about quite a bit but is not done
as much anymore as it was in the 90s
when that movie was first made and just
the idea that Celine that character in
Before Sunrise is talking about coming
to this city as a teenager and writing
in her journal and basically having a
conversation with herself based upon
what she wrote in that journal and
Richard linklater has some other you
know their Boyhood is about very
specifically about time and aging and
things like that but I think I I saw
Before Sunrise around the time that I
left that Monastery with the Navy guy
with the tattoo who taught me about
Memento Mori and so I've thought about
that and it's I think it's really
important to be cognizant of time and
just the idea that the moment is what we
have and there's so many ways to embrace
time but um maybe as an obsessive
traveler it's always puts me into this
thought experiment of how time is
playing out and how I'm making use of it
you know I just realized so uh I'll just
quickly say I'll add an 11th book so
that you're reading 11 instead of 10
with the little the little comma big by
John Crowley that's the novel that I was
describing earlier but I don't know if
I've ever asked you about fiction per se
we've spoken about Walt Whitman and
we've spoken a bit about poetry which I
suppose might be in many cases a form of
fiction
uh but largely when I've asked you about
writers and books it's all been
non-fiction
are there any particular fiction writers
or
fiction books that have had a
large impact on you or just impact on
you they come to mind that could have
been in the last few years could have
been 30 years ago it doesn't matter
that's a great question
interestingly like I'm fascinated by
Ramona clef fiction fiction that is
basically a sneeze away from real life
like on the road right and my wife it's
such a stereotypical male female thing
my wife gives me a hard time because she
loves novels she plows through novels
she eats them up and I always default to
non-fiction yeah but actually as a
traveler I find that fiction is it like
novels are infinite machines they
basically put you into the experience of
another human being and it allows you to
experience what it's like to live in
this country or to be a woman in this
part of the United States or or whatever
and and that's the great thing about
novels is that it sort of brings you
into the emotion of what it is and so I
found something that I've done more and
more as a traveler is not just read
travel books not just read travel guide
books but read novels written by people
who live in the country where you go to
and I was just in the Pharaoh Islands
Kiki my wife and I went to the Faroe
Islands and so it was interesting where
are the Pharaoh Islands the Pharaoh
Islands are north of Scotland South East
of Iceland and Southwest of Norway and
they're they're just mind-blowingly
beautiful and they're very Nordic gotta
pick your season I guess oh yeah no
we're there in August
and even then it was the weather was
unpredictable it's it's like a famously
unpritable place it's it's it's very
Nordic there their languages Nordic is
probably the closest
familiar languages is Icelandic but it
was so interesting like I read I had the
guidebook but I like read the the
Pharaoh Island Saga which is sort of
about the Haven culture adapting to the
introduction of Christianity and The Old
Man and the Sea I forget the name who
wrote that but it's about these old
fishermen who have always transported by
boat and but yet their sons are building
roads and traveling by roads it said in
the middle 20th century and so it's
about how basically these basically
Christianity is this globalized religion
that upended the the Heathen the Viking
religions of a thousand years ago the
fact and he talks he talks about time in
this book that basically The Men Who
sailed out to fish and didn't know when
they were coming back time meant nothing
to them time was a huge expansive thing
their sons who who traveled by roads
time is a very concise thing and they
they had a much less philosophical
attitude towards time and so it's
another book I haven't finished along
with Oliver bertman's book but it was so
interesting to look at this great irony
that one of the books you haven't yet
finished is the 4 000 weeks on the the
finite nature of Life yes right now
actually you you partially know this but
years ago I thought I was going to write
a book called time wealth and then I
told my friend Mike who does my website
it's like yeah I want to write it but I
don't have time for it he's like okay
how about that you don't have time to
write time wealth okay but yeah no I'm
surrounded by books right now maybe I
should do a podcast about reading one
half to one quarter of a book and then
talking about that based upon you guys
so far but it was so interesting being
in the Pharaoh Islands I saw that like
school let out we were in this Village
one day and a lot of the kids this kid
was walking by he was sort of nerdy in a
way that I was nerdy when I was about 10
years old and he was watching an English
language YouTube video on his phone and
a part of me thought this kid needs to
be where he is but also I remember being
a nerdy 10 year old kid and the fact
that he's in his second language he's
watching a video and so I think this
conversation about how new ideas and new
technologies change societies it's been
going on in the Pharaoh Islands ever
since they decided the Norse people
decided to introduce Christianity and
sort of append the Pagan religion it's
been changing since they built roads and
then The Men Who fished were a different
from The Men Who drove cars and so this
is a roundabout way of saying I don't
really read that many novels but it was
interesting how they tied together and
again it's that empathy that the novels
put you into characters in a way that
non-fiction really can't you get
information from non-fiction which is
why I love nonfiction but then
they're just these empathy machines
putting you through a novel allows you
to empathetically experience other lives
and oftentimes if it's written from the
perspective of the country you're
visiting in any part of the world it's
just a great resource to have as a
traveler
yeah I love novels as empathy machines
yeah I would guess and this is pointing
the finger back at myself also the
people who are
historically heavily predisposed to
non-fiction probably are not suffering
from a lack of information in their
lives and so maybe an IV of empathy the
vis-a-vis some really compelling fiction
I might be it might be a good
counterbalancer well there's information
versus ritual because I was just
thinking another thing that I touched on
the book is the idea that the idea that
we get information from books is pretty
new that we get our stories that the
idea that a novelist creates a story
that we read and we recognize him as the
author of that is pretty new because
historically stories are shared in
communities and you can still go to
parts of the world where you know
literally or metaphorically stories are
shared around a campfire and nobody owns
the story it's just this person who
tells the story is the one who tells it
the best not the person who wrote it and
so I think people like you and me are a
little bit obsessed with information
forget that so much of uh human
resonance comes through stories and even
shared stories and even come common
stories and I think that's why we have
Urban myths that's why we have all these
these weird stories that float around
because there's certain things that we
gravitate toward and yeah so maybe
that's a resolution another thing for
your pilgrimage read some fiction read
some Japanese fiction and see how you do
because it is information
can be an obstacle sometimes how much
information do you need I don't know I
don't know the answer that I I'm
swimming it every day so yeah remember
one of my friends and past podcast guest
Derek sivers who's a phenomenal guy his
story is just insane I mean it's like
philosopher king computer programmer who
is also a circus ringleader and traveled
around as a musician playing at state
fairs I mean his whole story is insane
and just amazing and he said at one
point
and I think I'm getting it right but I
could be paraphrasing if more
information were the answer we would all
be billionaires with six-pack abs
I just thought that was fantastic so let
me read another snippet here
and we we can explore it a bit or rather
I can listen to you explore it
quote travel can give us context for the
Life Choices we make at home and by
exposing us to other ways of living help
us fine-tune those choices in a way that
makes our home life Fuller
any stories examples expansions on that
I think sometimes I mean this also
applies to the idea of buying in on
property with your parents like you do
in other countries but basically we have
this set of choices often information
driven set of choices that we abide by
at home but then when we see other
people approaching love in a different
way for example if you go to a country
that's still sort of navigating the line
between arranged marriages and love
matches right which Korea was when I was
there and it was interesting to see how
there's sort of a fairy tale I lucked
out I fell in love with my soulmate but
there's we detached this fairy tale
significance to love that the Koreans I
met at the time did not that they saw a
lot of my Korean students that well
Someday I'm gonna
enter into an arranged marriage and I'm
gonna make the most of it love becomes
work after a certain point right and I
think that sometimes we fetishize love
as something that solves problems and
something that is bestowed upon us as
opposed to something that we work for
and even though I've said multiple times
that I married my soul mate part of one
of our vows was William Carlos Williams
poem The Ivy Crown we will it so and so
it is past all accident basically that
love is something that is a miracle and
a gift that happens in your life but
it's also something you have to work for
it's not something that just falls into
your lap that you have to will it so so
that it's not an accident and that the
miracle of us meeting is something that
we also have to keep willing years after
we're married we have to keep
underpinning
that Miracle of love with willpower and
I think that's something that was really
underpinned when I was in Korea just
knowing there are people there who
didn't necessarily have the storybook
soap opera love but they were partnered
with somebody for reasons that made
sense to their family and they were
going to make it work and so that helped
me contextualize and it was a long fuse
because it was the 90s that I was in
Korea and it was it was the late 20
teens before I met my wife but just that
idea of Love is an active thing as as
something that is something that you uh
you will sow in a certain way that's an
example of something that was
contextualized in a really useful way
but the cultures actually Latin America
is the same we're talking about
full-throated love I mean yeah have you
been to Cuba I have not been to Cuba I
have not I would love to at some point
yeah I loved Cuban they're Piropos I
don't know if they still do it like here
it might be called cat calling but
there's so much art to it in Cuba that
basically a guy gave me like a proposed
lesson when I was in Cuba once it's like
if you can cook like you walk I'll marry
you right now you know
maybe it doesn't translate very well but
Latin cultures are so much more verbal
and so much more artistic about the
courtship ritual right yeah again in the
midwest We Stand far apart in in Korea
it's much more family oriented but in
Latin America I think maybe my love
language that I can now use in my wife
was sharpened by the context of being in
this country where people are very
unambiguous about their statements of
Love even if they're not sure if it's
love yet you know they're just they're
just throwing things out there and I
think it makes their days more
interesting you know
yeah yeah
they're uh Nary a sharper contrast could
be found than between
I would say you know Korea and like Cuba
Street Beetle plus yeah or or maybe
between Kansas and Cuban Street budopas
for that matter no there were some
things directly translated that with me
punched in the nose in Kansas that these
Cuban guys they oh yeah it worked for
them so they could make it work yeah
different different culture
what would you suggest people perhaps
pay attention to or
how they can open the surface area in
their life for making contact with New
Life Choices that could translate back
to home while they travel
is it just a general awareness I mean if
so how do you cultivate that a lot of
people see a lot of amazing things and
experience a lot of amazing things when
they travel and then they come home and
it's
you know control Z undo back to normal
so
what are some of the
efforts that can be made if any come to
mind well attention again is a good word
it's sort of a refrain in this
conversation and I was literally
thinking of of tick not Hans washing
dishes analogy are you familiar with
this yeah you should definitely describe
it I mean this is some book I read of
his that this was the one thing that
stuck with me so yeah please describe it
as a guy who's otherwise incompetent in
the kitchen compared to his wife uh I'm
good at washing dishes right so this
really appealed to me as an otherwise
incompetent kitchen guy but he's
basically saying that whatever you
should you should do the life that you
live is in the moment right now and so
whatever you do you should be thankful
for the miracle of what you're doing and
so as you're washing the dishes as
you're washing these bowls and holding
them under the water you should give
thanks for the fact that you have this
life and that this is what you are doing
that you're not thinking back to the
dumb thing you said in a conversation
yesterday you're not thinking about what
you're gonna do tomorrow that you're
celebrating the miracle that is these
Bulls well I think travel is something
it's sort of gives us that Miracle it's
it's otherness it sort of forces us into
a kind of attention that is special that
can be a letdown and actually coming
back into 90 degree heat from the
Pharaoh Islands in Kansas is a little
bit of let down I'm trying to adjust
I've done this a million times but still
it's like oh man I just wish I was still
walking in the rain in the Faroe Islands
but I think that is almost the metaphor
that travel reminds you that life is
important I guess the the dishes that
every dish you wash that every hike you
take that every street corner you turn
around and see a Samba school dancing
towards you that you didn't expect to
see it in Rio
that that is what your life consists of
and so not to be too heady and
philosophical about this but that's
really what popped in my head just the
idea that
at its best travel is a spiritual thing
it connects you to the to the nowness of
being alive and that's some that's
actually something I need to work on
right now Tim because I'm really missing
the Pharaoh Islands with the the cute
little sheep and the Beautiful views and
just that feeling of Viking otherness
that I felt there that I have to reset
and remind myself to take that attitude
that dishwashing nowness
of the travel experience back home and
it's it's never a perfectable thing as
proven by the fact that I'm sort of
wishing I was in the Pharaoh Islands now
but that's the best answer I can give
it's just that washing the dish of this
moment now and realizing that this is
what the moment that you have is what
you have and it should be celebrated
yeah for sure and some version of that
story he's probably told multiple
versions that also stuck with me have
had an additional wrinkle to it which
was
if while you're washing the dishes
you're thinking about the juicy apricot
or something Plum that you're going to
eat afterwards if you're thinking about
this Plum or apricot while you're
washing the dishes when you're eating
the plum or the apricot you're going to
be thinking of something else
and that always stuck with me it's like
okay if you're looking forward to this
thing and you're willfully unaware and
blind to what you're doing on route to
that thing when you get there you're
going to be thinking about the next
thing yeah and it's going to be Pearls
Before Swine so don't be a swine
uh that's so good and and it's it's
actually hard to quote a specific book
for the dishwashing analogy that took
not Han has because he's a preacher
right he's he's a spiritual man he would
give a sermon and people give sermons
often will Riff on the same idea several
times and so I think the dishwasher like
a stand-up comic working on is 60-minute
set yeah no totally totally yeah and
it's it's so funny and assembling a book
I don't know if you come up against this
but I had to pay for some of the quotes
I used especially the poetry and
actually I found a David Wagoner poem I
think through five bullet Friday there's
this David Wagner poem about like the
forest knows where you are let it find
you yeah so good and I wanted to use
that quote which I'm pretty sure I found
through through you somehow well he's
been dead since like for 10 years at
least but I had to pay his publisher a
hundred dollars to use like six lines of
that poem and so I'm thankful for taking
on this is a complete aside I'm thankful
for taking on for preaching his sermons
that I don't have to pay for his
beautiful language because uh you don't
have to pay for a sermon like you do for
a poem six measly lines cost me a six
hundred dollars David Wagner bless your
soul but
I know it didn't go in your pocket yeah
so when people hear the Woe Is Us
Publishers talking about how hard life
is don't let them fool you there are
actually some great economic models at
work that have kept some of them afloat
for a very long time some of them are
doing incredibly well so don't uh don't
lose any sleep over that and my
publisher didn't pay their publisher I
paid that in my own pocket that's rich
as they say I love it it was worth it it
was a good poem yeah yeah gotta get it
done one way or the other I want to
mention one thing from our first
conversation for people who may
not realize the power of the Google in
one particular capacity and that is
Googling your demographic and then what
you're contemplating doing right so we
talked a little bit about this so you
could type in
and this is just an example 35 years old
two kids one year of travel and you'll
likely find 20 blogs or who knows
Instagram probably at this point maybe
of people in that demographic who are
doing exactly what you're contemplating
doing so if you're like I can't do it
because I've got a dyslexic dog and just
like type it all into
Google and it's like oh wait a second
six people have already done this and I
can learn all about how they did it so
just for a little bit of inspiration and
tactical instruction I recommend that I
would love to zoom out for a minute and
just talk about the
second half of life so how are you
thinking about
next chapters for yourself and just how
you how you frame that for yourself
anything at all related to that
this is something I reflect on a little
bit in the new book and specifically I
quote Richard Rohr have you read much
Richard Rohr hmm I've you know I want to
say I recognize the last name r-o-e-h-r
is that r r o h r yeah oh it might be a
different person why don't you tell me
slash refresh my memory I may not know
who this is he has a book called Falling
upward which I think the subtitle might
be wisdom for the second half of life
and for a while I thought he was my own
Discovery and I asked him on my podcast
and then I found out he's friends with
like Oprah and Bono right that he's way
more famous than I thought he was yeah
you're right he had discovered this
Hidden Gem right like I found him in a
library and it's like oh my God this
guy's amazing everybody needs to know
about him and then then I realized that
actually Oprah and Bono are friends with
the guy
but Falling upward is about and I love
the analogy he says that in a way
America is the very first half of Life
focused Society
but he says that the first half of life
is creating the vessel of the form your
life will take the second half is
filling in that vessel oh I love that
it's falling upward it's a great book
recommendation it's so wise and it's so
smart he he uses the idea he has a lot
of analogies but he talks about Odysseus
we have this idea that Odysseus
you know we see Odysseus as this
traveler but then also he's also this
guy who comes home and has to court his
wife right and so there's another
adventure that actually happens after he
gets home
and I just love the idea of filling your
vessel it's like We As Americans are
obsessed with first half of life and you
and I have used this in a conversation
before it's achievement versus
appreciation right yeah it's outcomes
versus awe you know it's it's it's like
building a life you want versus living
the life that you've built right and so
it's something actually my wife is like
eight and a half years younger than me
she'll say nine but uh we talk about
this because because we're both above
the age of 40. and just the idea that if
you are still living by first half of
Life aspirations and values in the
second half of life then there's going
to be diminishing returns you know yeah
for sure actually interesting quote John
Muir I didn't know this John Muir made a
ton of money selling grapes to Hawaii
when he was young he was a good
businessman I did not know that yeah no
but then he seems like a challenging
just
from a logistics perspective in that day
and age just seems very challenging but
yeah okay well I think there were so few
great he was in California obviously but
he was shipping grapes to to Hawaii he
made a ton of money and then he decided
to just drop out and be the John Muir we
know he decided to walk around and
explore the Wilderness and and be at one
with his experience of Nature and
somebody said they talked to this guy I
think his name was Ian Harriman who was
a very rich magnet and they're like well
he's making more money than you you made
all this money and then you quit like
don't you want to be as rich as him and
he's like I already am richer than
Harriman because I have all the money I
need and he doesn't right I have all the
money I want and he doesn't and so I
think that's sort of second half of Life
wisdom when you realize that you've
built the vessel and it's sort of a it's
a it's a vessel that's worth filling up
now it might not be the vessel you
dreamed of when you were 22. but it's a
vessel that looks pretty good and now is
the time to start appreciating the life
that you're living being married
underscores it I travel in kind of a
different way now I think I have less of
a a g whiz approach to travel in some
ways I'll never match up to those first
Adventures I had when I was wandering
through the jungle and getting my ass
handed to me playing volleyball but now
I'm I've sort of have I sort of know
where I want to go back to I know where
I still want to go and I know that I
won't ever be able to go to everywhere I
dream of and that's okay right but I
have created a vessel that has travel
and has this woman I love and it has
this connection to this land in Kansas
and I'm not saying that I'm a perfect
example of first half second left but
I'm thinking about this because I think
the United States is an achievement
culture it's less so an appreciation
culture and if you are in second half of
life and you're still grinding to
achieve something you're still grinding
to compete with the guy next door well
maybe that has less happiness embedded
in it than just appreciating the life
that you've built for yourself and one
great thing about success that's another
thing we talked about in our last
podcast interview was success management
and I think I couldn't articulate that
as well eight years ago but it I think
success s Management is taking that
vessel and filling it in a way that that
enhances the life that you've built for
yourself I'm certainly not an expert
Richard rohrer would be a good guy to
speak to that he's a Franciscan priest
actually he's from Kansas originally wow
but it's something that is really
fascinated me I think he lives in
Albuquerque now
just the idea that yes focusing on
filling the vessel is really where I
should be now I shouldn't really be
competing
for my lot in the world in the way I was
when I was in my 20s and 30s because I
have become the person I am and now I
should enjoy it a little bit yeah I
agreed yeah I'm
definitely
meditating on all this and realizing as
I had before like number one don't want
to be the old guy at the club like I
really don't want to be that guy number
one number two it's not always this is a
metaphor obviously it's not always a
great idea to be the oldest Geezer in
like the NHL like it's a full contact
sport this is like individualistic
Achievement business is very full
contact including a lot of self-abuse
and flagellation and man you can only
take so many hits and so much abuse and
so many like physical or psychic
reconstructive surgeries before you're
like good Lord what am I doing to myself
so yes filling the vessel I agree with
that uh well Ralph the new book is the
Vagabonds way 366 meditations on
Wanderlust Discovery and the Art of
travel how did you decide why did you
decide to put this together
well it really came out of the pandemic
and in fact I I approached you I was
maybe during that time of depression in
2019 I'm like I want to write
vagabonding too and you talked me out of
it yeah effort your rationale basically
you know unless there's a whole lot of
new things to say don't sort of write
the the diet coke junior varsity version
of the book people know you for and that
was good advice but I also you know I
met Kiki I met my wife during that time
and we started reading books to each
other every morning there's a lot of
tick not Han wisdom that has been
collected into a day by day reading
books uh the Ross gay uh book of
delights we were reading to each other
and we were reading also uh Ryan
holiday's daily stoic which sort of
became a template for the book the
Vagabonds way became because that was a
page today book 366 chapters quote by a
stoic meditation with other contexts
reflection on what he said what that
stoic person was saying and so I
realized that maybe one way I could get
out of writing bag binding too one way I
could bring value to all my 25 plus
years of reading and about travel and
traveling was to have this idea that
basically my wife and I would go out and
we were engaging with ideas but we were
also connecting with each other and our
morning readings be it Ross gay or
ticknot Han
whoever we read that sort of set the
tone for the day and so I realized that
there really wasn't a travel equivalent
of this and that I'm a keeper of a
commonplace book you know I've been
saving quotes and thoughts for years and
years and years and I realized that I
had all all of this wisdom other
people's wisdom that I didn't know what
to do with and so I decided to put it
into this format
since I was getting so much out of this
daily ritual at home to write what I had
never seen before which is sort of a
travel version of The Daily stoic where
you get a meditation on a certain aspect
of travel and then or a quote about it
and then a meditation about that quote
and then almost like vagabonding even
though it's not vagabonding too it sort
of takes you through the Journey so
January is about being inspired for the
journey and why Journeys are important
and why it's important to take them now
February is about preparing for the
journey
in this information Saturn Society how
to best prepare for the journey March is
about getting started on the journey all
the way through until December is about
coming home and bringing that attitude
of travel home so much like my true love
and marriage it fell into my lap during
the pandemic and it's like this is the
book to write and so yeah it was it was
really fun engaging with it and
and I'm really excited to have it in the
world amazing
this might seem like a dumb question it
probably is so I think a full year is
365 days so is it 366 is Gen 1 to gen 1
is that the idea no it's leap year it's
sleepy leap year okay
got it got it yeah I do end on the
cultural context of New Year's
resolutions which is an old Babylonian
ritual it's an old Harvest ritual but I
didn't do January 1st twice I snuck in a
leap year just so that people wouldn't
have something
an empty day during a leap year so yeah
cover the bases you got to cover the
bases uh well we're all
always great to see you and I'm excited
about the new book as I am about all of
your writing I've read a ton of your
writing as I mentioned in the very
beginning you know vagabonding
shaped a lot of my experiences that then
contributed to the writing of the four
hour work week and I think it is for
people who are
perhaps not immediately drawn to
Extended Global Travel I will say that I
view vagabonding more as a philosophical
cleanse and reset that allows you to
approach life in a not necessarily
minimalist but more elegant thoughtful
deliberate way and for all of those
reasons I think it's tremendously
valuable as a as a book and a guide for
life
even if you have no intention of
traveling it is using travel as a
vehicle for exploring all these subjects
and similarly sounds like that's what
the 366 meditations are doing in the
Vagabonds way is there anything else you
would like to add people can find you of
course ralphpots.com and then on all the
social we'll link to all of that in the
show notes for this episode is there
anything else you'd like to add any
closing comments requests of the
audience anything at all well I was
thinking you know we've talked about
attention in the attention economy
sometimes your question is what would
you put on a billboard oh yeah let's do
it I think the last time I did that I
said time as well but but I was reading
the attention Merchants by Tim Wu and
the billboard was the original attention
economy device you know back in 19th
century France if you were stuck in an
intersection they painted a wall with an
advertisement for something to get your
attention and so I guess just you know
the travel reminds us of the
preciousness of real organic attention
and maybe maybe I don't know I like I
liked my idea the last time you know
that the time is wealth your true wealth
is time but maybe the the sign on the
billboard is Don't Look At Me Lend your
attention to life itself because the
attention economy is a trap in a way and
again I don't want to I don't want to
knock technology too much but attention
is such a gift and the moment is what we
have and so that's just something that I
reflected on listening to our last
conversation it's like yeah Billboards
are part of the attention economy so
maybe instead of looking in the
billboard we should just look at our
lives and and pay attention and wash our
dishes and and make the most of what we
have
yeah here here I agree with that and you
know it also made me think I have not
actually been through downtown Sao Paulo
but I have heard that they have removed
all Billboards or at least for a period
of time the entire city of Sao Paulo
which is a huge City had removed
Billboards or outdoor advertising and
it'd be fascinating to go there for the
conspicuous absence of that barrage just
to see what it's like because I've never
experienced that in any any modern city
of any size and Ralph
so great to see you I recommend people
check out the new book and all the
things you've written and we'll write
the Vagabonds weigh 366 meditations on
Wanderlust Discovery in the art of
travel
thanks for taking the time man really
appreciate it it's good to see you Tim
and let's meet somewhere in the world
someday yeah let's do it let's do it
it's been a while since since any
in-person Jam sesh so we'll make that
happen and for everybody listening
as always you can find links to
everything we discussed all the names
all the books all the things at tim.blog
podcast just search Ralph Rolf and it
will pop right up and until next time be
a little Kinder than is necessary and
take care